le bureau d'audiences publiques en
environnement se penchent ces jours ci
sur le projet minier matawinie de
l'entreprise nouveau monde gaffes et à
saint michel des saints dans lanaudière
le projet consiste à implanter une mine
de graphite pour produire 100 mille
tonnes par année de grafite naturel pour
les batteries au lithium ion et d'autres
applications industrielles
eric dosogne et le pdg de nouveaux
mondes grafite bonsoir monsieur désigné
bonsoir ses clients alors c'est un
projet ambitieux bien sûr une mine à
ciel ouvert de grafite naturel 100 %
électrique un projet sur 26 ans
est-ce que vous avez confiance que le
bape va donner une évaluation positive
de votre projet effectivement la semaine
dernière c'est super important les
audiences publiques c'est un processus
qui permet à la communauté locale et
autour pas tous les citoyens de poser
des questions je peux vous confirmer
après les premières audiences qu'ont eu
plusieurs questions et qui proviennent
de citoyens très favorable au projet
comment de démontrer par un sondage 80 2
% des gens sont très favorables à notre
présence ou favorables et met en oeuvre
pour ça qu'ils sont défavorables à notre
projet c'est important de comprendre
pourquoi sa seule salle amène des
préoccupations assurément un projet
minier
donc après six mille pages de des
changes avec les ministères plusieurs
millions $ d'études environnementales on
peut aujourd'hui affirmer que à
l'extérieur d'un rayon d'un kilomètre de
notre opération projetée on va seulement
avoir d impact faible est négligeable
dans ce milieu physique que le milieu
biologique et a contrario on va avoir un
impact très positif sur le milieu
maintenant au niveau retombées
économiques aux entrepreneurs et aux ce
que j'ai raison dit que les commissaires
du bape ont quand même remis en question
la méthodologie des sondages dont vous
parlez y'a pas de sondages par fait
d'être capable de sonder les
villégiateurs c'est quand même un défi
c'était ce qui était discuté durant les
audiences publiques ou de villégiateurs
dans cette région là qui sont pas tout à
fait d'accord avec le projet et qui ont
des inquiétudes sur leur milieu de vie
et sur le milieu touristique également
l'effet économique sur le tourisme
effectivement notre on était capable de
sonder à peu près une trentaine sur
quelques centaines au total on avait une
trentaine de villes et j'ai attaqué par
un échantillon statistique mais de ceux
trentaine de la majorité était quand
même fait
variable au projet c'est ce que le
rapport de légers qui est public
démontre c'est juste pas un
échantillonnage qui est esthétiquement
intéressant parce que les numéros de
téléphone des villégiateurs sont
difficiles à avoir son réseau ses seins
et non saint michel des saints
si on peut une numéro de téléphone dans
cette région là c'est difficile dès son
départ tout à l'extérieur du québec
le projet en soi donc je vais pas
m'éterniser sur les critiques mais
puisqu'il y en a dans le cadre du bape
ya beaucoup d'incertitude qui sont
soulevées d'inquiétude
des questions ont été posées notamment
sur la technologie de stockage des
résidus et il ya des groupes
environnementalistes qui parle de bombes
environnementale à retardement pour la
région modiste ce qu'on fait
fondamentalement assez sympa on prend la
gauche est dans un état d'équilibré en
ce moment dans la nature on extrait
cette roche là on sort le 5 % graphique
et on remet le matériel dans le même
état d' équilibre donc les techniques de
gestion des risques du conte propose qui
a été haut la main applaudi par les gens
du ministère de l'environnement durant
le bape
c'est une technique permet de remettre
dans les mains dans le même état
physico-chimiques le bactérielles qu'on
a pris pour éviter le début des
réactions acide aux jeunes
donc c'est une méthode qui est utilisé
dans plusieurs dizaines d'opérations sur
la planète en 2020 on ne peut pas
construire un projet sans regarder ce
qui a été fait par le passé à s'assurer
qu'on développe un projet qui répond à
tous les normes
si vous écoutez les audiences qui ont eu
lieu la semaine dernière notre vice
présidente en environnement très bien
répondu à la plupart des questions qui
tout comme les ministres de
l'environnement construction
exploitation fermeture de la mine dans
un quart de siècle à 350 millions de
dollars
c'est exact exactement à capitaux ces
350 millions de dollars est aussi 49
millions de dépenses annuelles de coûts
de 10 notation annuellement et le projet
serait rentable à partir de quand pour
vous nous c'est à partir de l'année 2
qu'on commence ces deux points six ans
de bep bac qu'on dit en anglais de
retour sur l'investissement aurait pu
par la suite c'est très rentable
annuellement avec des ventes d'environ
200 millions de dollars canadiens pour
des dépenses de 49 millions
4 millions 600 mille ont été investis le
20 décembre 2018 un prêt
d'investissement québec où ces de
l'actionnariat c'est de l'actionnariat
dissipation est ce que vous demandez
est-ce que vous avez besoin de plus
d'argent d'investissement qui dit qu on
est en train discute en ce moment le
financement global de notre projet notre
actionnaire le plus important le groupe
plein coeur de londres
oui sont un expert du domaine minier qui
ont déployé plus de 2 milliards de
dollars américains dans les douze
dernières années pour la construction
projets miniers comme le nôtre ils y ont
commis sont intéressés à financer le
projet mais avec un support
gouvernemental pour montrer un peu le
coup une partie de ses ressources leur
reste québécoise est ce que vous êtes
certain qu'on n'arrivera pas à des cas
comme nemaska lithium par exemple qui se
retrouve sous la protection des
tribunaux
la grosse différence avec notre truc
c'est qu'il ya eu aussi deux
d'excellentes exemple admin minier on
pense est championne aaron on pensait
aussi ce côté du fad du dollar et des
matériaux qu'on connaît très bien qu on
l expertise le graphite c'est la même
chose depuis 1876 combine du greffe et
au québec dans les 45 dernières années
le québec est la juridiction la plus
importante dans le monde occidental
termes de production graphite avec qui
mme rice qui réfutait carbone avec des
îles avec hasbro fait à notre dame du
lot donc on doit cette expertise là dans
l'équipe et on sait comment faire donc
ça enlève beaucoup de risques
au démarrage d'entreprises que je
réponde mauvaises nouvelles annoncées
votre propos prochainement
non non et éventuellement garantie on
connaît comme amine et du graphite
et comme un construisent opérations
hockey mais cela dit le prix n'est pas
le meilleur les réserves sont en hausse
quand on regarde l'évolution du prix
d'un type de greffes fit parce qu'il ya
plusieurs types de graphiques puis on
veut le voir on est en baisse quand même
depuis 2012 ou 2012 une frénésie quand
la chaîne a décidé d'annoncer que c'est
un matériau stratégiques et en même
temps que les états unis l'union
européenne il ya une pénurie temporaire
qui montrent moins beau et en 2012 et
fonctionnaires à normale sup riz voilà
le 2012 est anormalement élevé donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est un
marché de 800 mille tonnes par année de
greffer dans le monde grosso modo tous
les types de produits sanguins
vous venez de parler de tesla tesla
maintenant 400 mille véhicules par année
en achètent pour 40 mille tonnes de
grafite par année artificielle
artificielle et lectures et naturel
c'est un mélange des deux on a besoin de
deux tonnes de flocons de graphite pour
faire une tonne de matériel d'anodes
donc grosso modo 100 environ 40 mille
tonnes de flocons donc si on pense à
tesla qui va croire à un million de
véhicules sont pense à volkswagen
ils veulent faire 3 millions de
véhicules environ 25 un moment donné on
a le plus gros projets dans le monde
occidental bien on va a besoin d'en
trouver plus merci monsieur desrosiers
merci beaucoup merci